right we've got the live stream going
now people welcome everyone to um
February 7th infrastructure meeting
um I've got apologies
first we have them from the mayor and
from Ms cook they're away on other
Council business and I also have
apologies from
counselor Campbell and bond so can I
have someone move those please
moved Leslie seconded Darren put that
all those favor all right let's carry
that takes us to the public forum
uh Carolyn would you like to
come up to the
just so that we can get a microphone is
that going to be easy enough
and we've got a video to play as well
you're going to instruct malavika when
you want the uh yep
can you hear me
I'll just move that mic forward Tony's
passing it on something thank you hi I'm
Karen of Western kyota and I'm from
blind citizens New Zealand Southland
branch and with me is my husband Tony
and also Victor West and we're here to
talk to you today about audio just
announcements on Butters
and a little bit of History before the
video and that is to tell you that in
2013 December there was a new bus
service started in invercargill and it
was launched I think around about the
3rd of December that year and on that
bus route which the I think there was
four buses that went on the different
routes throughout the city there was
audio announcements that was fantastic
because
invercargill was one of the first cities
in New Zealand to have audio
announcements on the buses which helped
blind people people with low vision and
people who are deaf-blind but not only
just us it also assisted new people who
were in news invercargill and also
tourists so they knew what where they
were in the city
um and then so in 19 2014 we made a
video and we want to play you the third
section of that video which is a good
demonstration of what we had in those
days on our buses so can you play the
video please some people wake up and
check their phones
check the weather check the news I don't
know what that is getting around safely
and comfortably is important for all of
us we've got some tips on how to help
your blind passengers have a smooth trip
whether they're after work study or
party
always remember when assisting blind
people they all have different needs
provide verbal explanations of what's
about to happen
ask how can I help you
give your arm when guiding
and remember you may not be able to see
that a passenger has a disability
Hannah arrives at the airport terminal
hello that's at the beginning of the
video we need applying the food
that's the wrong clip
um this is the link that you gave us
Carolyn that was the link
I know but I believe there is a way of
getting just to the third clip my son
did yeah
we just want the buses you don't want to
see the taxis or the airport is there a
way of fast forward 40. Andy is the next
video
again
took the horn when you arrived
by bus
in invercargill all bus stops have a
braille sign attached on the print sign
it has the 0800 must smart number on it
plus the number of the bus stop
pan finds the right bus by using the
audio announcement facility
and Andrea has problems hearing as well
as being blind but she stops to listen
for that audio announcement making sure
she's at the right place
if a blind person is using a white
support cane this means they require the
floor to be lowered because they have a
physical disability as well
reacted to see you
if a blind person is paying by cash have
the bus ticket and then verbally count
out the chains so they know how much
money they have blind vision impaired
and deafblind passengers depend on
hearing the audio announcements so they
know where to get off the bus if the
audio announcements are not working
please tell the blind person when they
pay so they're aware there's a technical
fault
some passengers may prefer to be guided
onto the bus like Hannah is here
ready
not a problem
here
a driver can ask if the person would
like help scanning their bus smart card
some people who have a little vision may
wish to scan the cat themselves if the
driver shows them where the machine is
the machine beeps and the driver hands
the card back in this case telling
Hannah how much money is left on it
drivers should make sure that a blind
passenger knows where they can find a
vacancy please ensure your blind
passengers are seated before starting
off on the bus
a good thing your seat next to you as
you some passengers may ask to be let
off between designated bus stops blind
passengers will listen for the nearest
Stop audio announcement and then may
call to the driver reminding them where
they'll want to get off this ensures
they get off where they need to
here the driver confirms with the blind
passenger that this is the location
where they wish to get off
if for any reason you're unable to stop
the bus at the edge of the curb please
let your blind or Vision appeared
passengers know particularly if there's
something that's going to be obstructing
their passage to the footpath
as a bus driver you may not always know
if you have a passenger with a vision
impairment as not everyone uses a white
cane or guide dog so don't be surprised
if a passenger asks you about audio
announcements or where they can find a
vacant seat remember that if you have a
passenger who requires the floor to be
lowered to do this and tell a blind
person before they get off the bus
everybody has arrived at the destination
safely and with the help you're
providing it's time to get on with the
party
so you can turn it off now if it's just
us
um so that was a training visit video
however I just wanted to show you that
um we used to have audio announcements
on our buses 2020 the change the bus
routes and the audio announcements
weren't appropriate any longer so we
asked
um if we could have the audio
announcements back we were told that yes
they will come back in time but it's now
um two and a half years later and we
still haven't seen any audio
announcements people like Vic West
um uses the buses all the time Hannah
uses the buses I used to use the buses
I'm not sure how to get on the bus now
but anyway there's blind people Envision
and people and deafblind people still
using buses here in invercargill a lot
of the other cities here in New Zealand
are starting to put audio announcements
on their buses and we had it I'm pretty
sure that blind citizens gave
um we know I I know we gave Eddie cook
from ICC a um
a little bit of difference award and I
think we might have given one here to
you as well but I'm not sure I can't
remember but anyway
it's really important now because with
the New Zealand
accessibility bill for all that's um
being in House at present with um select
committee and also the U.N convention on
the rights of persons with disabilities
you have an obligation as a council to
provide
accessible transport for all people
including blind vision impaired and
deafblind people so I just want to say
that whatever happens in the future with
regards to public transport it's
important that that transport is
accessible to us all and I know that Vic
would really appreciate it as well as
other people that use the bus so
basically that's all I need to say at
this stage but we would like to be a
blind citizen Southland branch would
like to be involved with any new
um co-design on the new public transport
for invercargill thank you thanks for
that Carolyn um we've got about
three four minutes left for questions so
I can open up to anyone who wants to ask
the question of Carolyn
not for Caroline but she has asked a
question of council are we going to be
able to get back to her with an answer I
think as chair I'm going to ask that we
have something either comes back to this
committee or to Carolyn uh in a month
before a month is up so either either of
a status is that chair we can bring a
report back to the next 30 minutes yeah
okay Carolyn we'll actually advise you
before it goes to print so great thank
you
thank you organization
code designing the new um bus services
that looking at in the next
in the future right we have a question
from councilor Germany you just would be
interested in how user-friendly air city
is not just in buses but wider and
particularly with the CBD for
um people with vision imperman those
sorts of things
um there has been some criticize
criticisms about them all I know
um
some people I I personally like them all
the color schemes and it is quite good
but I know that um I have a friend whose
vision impaired and finds that the
farmer's building is very bright and she
said you can't go there anymore it's too
Cleary for her
um it's very difficult talking about the
outside of the CBD at this stage because
it's stored a lot of the Landscaping I'm
not sure because you have trouble with
the um Water Gardens and the rain
Gardens and do you step into them by
mistake because I know some people are
concerned about that
yeah we're trying to keep people away
from that area until it's finished so
it's a little bit early yet to know how
people are going to get on but I know
some there is some concern about the
rain Gardens and there's no indication
like no tactile maybe need some more
tactiles uh indicators on the ground to
let people know they're coming to a
garden as it's like now that's pouring
rain you don't want someone to step into
a garden and get wet feet
thank you okay one more question from
councilman I'm just wondering um were
you given a reason do you
know why they said they stopped the
voicings on the buses
um well they didn't give us a reason but
our our reasoning was that Eddie cook
was a person who used to be
um
managing the um buses for you know the
public transport and that in 2013 and we
certainly lobbied
um this Council around that time for
audio
announcements it took quite a while for
him to understand it but he certainly
did and he got that underway but once
the um Roots were changed in 2020 then
of course the audio announcements became
Obsolete and I don't know why council at
that stage when changing the um division
you know they're looking at the new bus
routes why they didn't actually find out
how
um how that was done previously
contacted Eddie cook I don't know if he
still works there but he used to work at
the railway station for
um the Kiwi rail in Wellington and they
might have been able to contact him and
find out how he had done that but but it
certainly was great I know that the
first time I experienced this audio
announcements on a bus was in
Switzerland and it was in German and I
actually knew that we were in the right
suburb because I recognized the name of
the suburb even though I couldn't speak
German so that's quite cool thanks
everyone thank you okay thanks very much
car Carolyn we appreciate you coming in
thank you
okay
was it the lights
on Council Scout
well that takes us now to the minutes of
the infrastructure committee
held on 6th of December 2022
uh can I have someone move that they are
true and correct please uh moved Council
oil second
pania
um
before I put that motion I just there's
a part of the minutes that talk about uh
a waste net review being completed by 31
March now Aaron do you just want to
update us that that may not be able to
quite be done
absolutely thank you chair
um I spoke um last year about us uh
engaging a review of wastenet both of
the governance arrangements and a little
bit of a brief look at whether or not
waste net was fit for purpose
um just in terms of there being some
change around the elected members who
are representing the various different
councils at the table some of them
weren't in appointed at the time that we
made that agreement so we just want to
take a little bit of extra time just to
bring that committee back together and
talk everybody through why we're doing
the review and the process just to make
sure that everybody is comfortable and
we don't bring a review back with people
sort of questioning what was the purpose
of that so just in order to be able to
do that we're probably going to need to
push that timeline out by about a month
just to bring that meeting together and
make sure everybody is on board will we
we have a meeting a first official
meeting of for this year of wastenet by
end of Feb or Med March or possibly end
of Feb just getting everybody's
calendars might be a bit tight I would
expect definitely by the end of March
okay
right
um any questions around the
around the minutes
in that case I'm going to put the motion
that that is true and correct all those
in favor
aye aye against that is Carrie thank you
um
temporary road closures for the surf to
City
that all us councilors will be doing
um
who would like to speak to them that'll
be Russell Russell
whilst Russell's getting set up there I
will just note though that we do need to
make a slight change to the
recommendations under recommendation
three we um in error didn't list the
roads that were going to be closed it is
in the body of the report but so that
the recommendation is Standalone we
should also include those so malavik has
been given a list of those roads just to
include in that recommendation okay
excellent thanks Russell
I've got planning council is linked down
this is a reasonably straightforward
procedural matter that we need I guess
technical approval to actually shut the
road for
um for the surf to City Event on the
12th of March um happy to receive any
questions some something that we've done
regularly and has been well organized it
is a little bit disruptive to the
otatara people but we have worked
through that and it's been pretty
successful over the years with a series
of measures that how people get through
it
Council Adelaide nothing different to
previous years Russell I'm seeing how
Stellar the otatara residents have
become to that disruption I'm happy to
move the three recommendations noting
that the third includes the streets
listed yeah we have the streets listed
uh the second door would you like to
speak I would like to speak yeah um
because you're running or because no no
because I sit on oh then you're right
next Southland and sir
thank you Leslie that seconded any
further questions comments for us
in that case I'll put the motion on all
those in favor
against that is Carrie thanks Russell
you're probably staying for the next one
the stopping of Road Bluff Highway Green
Hills
as well as Heather
welcome Heather
okay
[Music]
we have a number of proposed road
stopping in various forms so the bluff
Highway the buffet Highway Green Hills
is
um a road stopping which we have
previously had to council
but through that earlier process we
identified that we had a land area
incorrect in it so to make sure that we
actually followed the procedure we've
withdrawn that and we wish to start that
process again with the correct area all
those things end up with the minister of
lands as a sign off should it be
approved so we really felt that it was
in the best interest to start the
process again so this is really
starting a process of consultation with
those people in that section of land so
it's a piece of UN
formed Road Reserve which has land
Parcels all the way around it so we just
need to go through the formal process
under the Local Government Act to
advertise it and start that process of
consultation and depending on what
feedback we get we bring it back to
council for consideration in due course
okay and we have questions for us all
Leslie
both the recommendations yep
uh kind of a second there for that
thank you pania
um any comments or questions pretty
straightforward that we it's increased
in size
dramatically yes
um in that case I'll put the motion all
as in favor
against that is Carrie
we moved to
Green Point Road so the second Palm Road
stopping is right at the start we're
seeking approval from Council to stop
another portion of unthorne Road
um
which Hazel the right areas in it thank
you
um again it is a parcel of
um
road which is not being utilized as road
we've received a request from a
neighboring property owner
um that would like to
potentially once the road has been
stopped potentially utilize that and and
adjoin that to their land
um
there's very little else to say about
the process um we're just taking
approval to start that process again
okay that's straightforward
um I'll move the three recommendations
do I have a second there
uh thank you
Council Boyle are there any comments or
questions
no in that case
put the motion all those in favor
against that is carried
thank you Heather and Russell
Peter we have a solid waste update
foreign
I suppose this is a continuous
continuation of the previous reports
um the the same Graphics showing
different uh
uh variances to to uh projections we're
currently running at a
um
0.05 percent uh difference for ways to
landfill which is uh positive
uh and to make this quick uh could I
just um accept the reporters read and
ask if you have any questions
okay
um yeah I'll open the flow of questions
or
now and I was looking at some figures
here per capita
um
but we
I'm just trying to find them I saw them
here
what what are we per capita
about 100 grams
no no otherwise now how many kilos are
we tracking out oh sorry yeah um we we
were the previous report was 600 and
um
616 kilograms I believe
uh of this per carpeter I don't have it
off the top of my head
okay no that's okay we're just looking
at the at the previous waste net Target
started off
650. but we'll we'll get to those when
we get wasting it back moving pania just
just one more question I noticed with
the way uh the landpool tracking sort of
like increased but I was just looking at
the recycling yeah but slightly there's
a decrease
foreign
so the the recycling is actually
increased slightly yeah it's increased
very very slightly two percent below
December yeah so for the month we were a
bit lower but overall we're higher yeah
okay uh further questions
Peter
now
in that case uh the recommendation
we received a report note the waste
landfill data and Trends and that
recycling data and Trends can I have
someone moved that thanks Leslie
secondary
thank you grant I'll put that all those
in favor
aye
against that is Kerry thanks Peter
putting this trip
moves us to the activities report
[Music]
um
okay
right Aaron do you want to speak to
speak to the activities yeah well
anything that you you stand out some of
it's straightforward and covering the
really beach access and stuff just
noting the Steed Street reseal
yes so probably one of the key ones I
just want to draw attention to is the
fact that we have had a better run of
the ariti beach access this year
um there was some proactive maintenance
and additional monitoring put in place
after receiving feedback from Council
um
we understand that the weather's
probably also been a little bit generous
to us though this year so there's
probably been a little bit of a
combination of us putting in place some
more proactive maintenance as well as
the weather
um causing a little bit of difference
around how the sand moves into the low
spots on that access road this year but
either way we certainly haven't had the
problems that we experienced last year
over the summer period despite the quite
dry weather
the one that I did just wish to speak to
as well was the stead Street reseal that
was a piece of work that we were a
little bit concerned about the impact on
the community we've had very good
feedback though around how quickly the
team were able to get that work done and
that the community only experienced one
afternoon really of disruption that the
team got in there made sure that the
reseal was done in the afternoon and
evening took advantage of those long
daylight hours and had a good run of
whether we're able to get that completed
in in one evening which was a great
outcome
yeah the other thing I wish to speak to
which isn't written in the activity
report because it's a bit of a moving
Feast it's just an update around
um our water awareness
um we're obviously getting a little bit
of rain at the moment which will be
pushing um our need for water
restrictions away from us
um but I guess I'd just remind everybody
that we do find that unless we continue
to get those consistent lots of rain uh
one lot of rain isn't necessarily enough
to stop us from having water
restrictions this year but we'll
continue to monitor that we definitely
don't expect to be having them in the
coming weeks the way we would have been
a few weeks ago if we hadn't had these
periods of rain but we'll continue to
monitor whether or not we do need them
possibly later in February or early
March
thank you um I see that Scottish Hall is
competing with Splash Palace
um are we are we confident of the
Plumbing in in the Scottish Hall you
know that obviously we've got a burst
valve but is it uh do we go through and
and actually make sure that
it's not old yes so the the team have
advised that they don't believe that it
was
um a lack of Maintenance issue it was
just an unfortunate event
okay but a significant one nonetheless
right
um do I have a quick we have some
questions here we're going to start
Grant Trish then Leslie thanks yeah um
just with respect to the um
successful application for the funding
for cycling so note that the 2018
cycling strategy
it's reference to has there been any
updates
in terms of we're cycling South and
around their strategy for cycling going
forward or is that still relevant that
2018 report I'll ask Russell to come to
the table and speak to that one since
it's his bread and butter
afternoon again
um in terms of the strategy no we
haven't updated strategy but the
strategy Still Remains to be
um
reasonably valid and the the areas that
we've been working on
um are still those Focus areas it's one
of those pieces of strategy work that we
are looking to um
re start to work forward within the next
few months um with a new with the new
elected members as representatives and
making sure that the governance group
around ride South and it still becomes
appropriate
the strategy is really important for
when we apply for government funding
that it actually starts to align with
those the strategies of
um I guess those other funding strains
where we can actually get quite a
significant amount of money the
transport choices packages I guess one
indication of an area where with the
right those right elements in there you
can be quite successful in getting
funding for your community projects
right so so the strategy document was
useful in getting the funding but we
have the opportunity to change
potentially some of those cycling
strategies
always will actually grow as we actually
learn more about how we want to have a
um I guess active transport available to
the community in The Wider sense and
cycling Southland is involved in that
strategy cycling Southland has one of
the seats at the table yes but I guess
that's part of that governance group
structure about how we might want to
progress and change it
thank you
Trish
um with regard to the housing
um statistics effort assignment but a
couple of questions
um so
there are do you take everyone who comes
to you and put it on a waiting list
um so there's a prioritization framework
that the team worked through as to I
guess who gets priority on on that list
yeah and so I mean I see that there's no
um houses that vacated so with 89 on you
know this could just grow exponentially
do those people have an understanding
how long the wait is or could be
um that's my understanding Heather I
don't know if you've got anything
further to add but
if if you've got anything to add
otherwise
yeah
so every applicant who um
makes an application whether it's
accepted or whether it's declined we
give them a reason for uh for decline
um and that's whether they meet our
criteria and that's age
um their asset eligibility and their
income eligibility when they're approved
um and they are placed on the waiting
list we give them an indication of the
length of time that potentially they
will be on the waiting list for
depending on our current numbers on the
waiting list so with 18 no just I have a
real problem with this thinking of
people sitting there you know and it's
their time is getting the career
decreased and this 89 places people
still waiting so that's the total
waiting list on their priority list
those are the those are the people who
are eligible for a unit now
um those are the ones that are of more
concern because yes so how long oh you
don't know how long a piece of string is
like this currently our waiting list is
getting up to about 18 months right for
priority list right
so even though there's been no one go
out on that month it actually can be
faster than that I suppose
yeah we unfortunately we can't say how
many are going to become available it's
just quite concerning that there's so
many isn't that really yeah
thanks Heap thank you thank you hear
that Leslie yeah thanks Mr chair mine
was also a hell
of a help you might need to
um I was just going to
to ask and I realize it's the priority
and secondary number combined combining
of 89 but previously it's an unusually
high figure and secondly if it is
have you can you give us some idea of
why it's a higher bigger than it would
normally be for a December
so I looked at the figures for December
and I've also asked
um a housing officer to contact people
who have been on air waiting list for
longer than 12 months
and to find out whether they are still
wanting to be on the waiting list and
she's going through that at this stage
um it has got a little bit higher
but that
could be just the circumstances at the
moment I'm
we're we're hoping that it will come
down there's no particular Trend showing
up from people who are desperate because
they've tried every rental possibility
and so forth you're not getting a
particular feedback on not particularly
we are offering like we're giving advice
of where they might be able to find
alternative accommodation
um and you unfortunately
it just seems to be the way things are
at the moment
okay thank you any further questions on
the activity report
and that being the case then we have uh
two recommendations one to receive the
report
to a b and c as stated on the screen
um can I please have someone move those
ah thank you grant seconded counselor
Scott
I'm going to put those motions all those
in favor
aye against that is carried that is the
end of the
public part of this meeting
um we now wish to move into public
excluded for the reasons of
there are four items confirmation of
minutes road stopping of flagon Street
Bluff disposal planned in mersey Street
and potential disposal of endowment land
and 91 earn Street kind of someone
please move we're going to PE move
counselor Scout second the Council of
Germany put emotionalize in favor
against this past thanks very much